[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir la guinée
sera t-elle capable d'organiser la can
2025 la confédération africaine de
football s'est rendu à conakry ce
mercredi pour en avoir le coeur net
compte rendu de la visite qu'elle débute
ce jour
81 morts au niger suite des pluies
diluviennes depuis juin on dénombre en
tout 200 mille sinistrés l'eau continue
de monter sur les rives du fleuve
phénomènes météo rare dans un pays
habituellement très sec
et ce soir nous recevons les patrons le
groupe mythique ivoirien de zouglou qui
fête ses 20 ans de carrière avec un
concert événement le 10 septembre
prochain au zénith de paris retour sur
leur carrière et sont avec nous
[Musique]
on ouvre ce journal par les inquiétudes
de la confédération africaine de
football qui s'est rendu ce mercredi à
conakry afin de savoir si la guinée
serait capable d'assurer l'organisation
de la 35e édition de la coupe d'afrique
des nations en 2025 la junte au pouvoir
at elle réussi à rassurer la mission de
la caf ont fait le point notre
correspondant malik de quitter
l'organisation de la plus grande
compétition sportive s'annonce comme un
grand défi pour la guinée il faut le
dire le pays qui manque cruellement
d'infrastructures qu'elles soient
sportives hospitalière et même routière
malgré les travaux entrepris dont
l'avancé peine encore à être constatés
sur le terrain et en contexte politique
instable les autorités guinéennes aux
arts assure mardi dernier le colonel
mamadou doumbouya emilion décret
déclarant l'organisation de la can 2000
vend 50 d'intérêt national est
prioritaire et aujourd'hui on peut dire
clairement que la pression est sur le
ministère des sports et depuis 5
septembre il ya eu effectivement toute
une dynamique 5 72 une dynamique qui a
été mise en place pour justement se dire
que la can 2000 25 ans fait pour la
guinée c'était un véritable levier de
développement et aujourd'hui on a fait
une vraie priorité et à l'engagement du
président et la crédibilité aussi des
pays qui est mis en jeu donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui on ne peut plus
reculer on ne peut qu'avancer la guinée
est plus que prête à organiser la carte
2025 et qu'on sera au rendez vous du
stic grands événements mais pour
certains observateurs les sciences à
2025 l'ensemble une joie d'organiser une
coupe d'afrique des nations sa demande
le respect d'un cahier des charges avant
quand on était à 16 ou non au retrait
cette coupe d'afrique des nations
c'était quatre stades qui était demandé
par la confédération africaine de
football maintenant puisqu'on est à 24
équipes ces six stades minimum qu'il
faut avoir pour organiser cette coupe
d'application alors aujourd'hui on n'a
même pas un stade opérationnel on est à
trois ans de cette organisation de la
can en 2025 par quel miracle on parle et
on va réaliser on est dans la tradition
de ce truc quoi moi je ne crois pas
parce que la transition a une autre
priorité la priorité c'est dépassé et
des militaires au pouvoir à un civil
alors de nombreuses rumeurs su en
retrait de la can 2000 25 à la guinée ce
que ces derniers mois difficile de
savoir si cette visite à conakry a
rassuré les dirigeants de la caf
dans l'actualité ce soir il y à aussi la
sortie de la chef de la diplomatie
française contre la jante malienne
catherine colonna a déclaré que le
pouvoir naviguer à vue d'échec en échec
quelques semaines après le retrait
militaire de la france le mali le pays
est toujours en proie au djihadisme et
la violence on écoute un ministre
française des affaires étrangères
c'est ainsi qu'au mali nous voyons
progresser les groupes terroristes armés
dans tout le pays les maliens déplacés
par milliers
tandis que le régime auteur d'un double
coup d'état sans prendre un jour au
danemark le lendemain la côte d'ivoire
est toujours à la france pour tenter de
faire oublier qu'ils naviguent à vue
d'échec en échec
atteler un groupe de mercenaires russes
le climat politique sous tension au
tchad depuis le début de la semaine le
dialogue national qui se veut inclusif
on veut vivre mick jeudi des dizaines de
militants du parti les transformateurs
de succès mazerat ont été arrêtés alors
qu'ils tentaient de se mobiliser pour
une manifestation qui était prévu ce
vendredi et ce matin des forces de
l'ordre ont encerclé le siège du parti
où passe au niger où de fortes pluies
ont fait plus de 80 morts les deux
régions de maradi et zinder sont les
plus impactées et l'eau continue de
monter sur les rives du fleuve le point
avec notre correspondant à niamey à
relire à
sinistrés c'est le triste bilan était
ici au niger marquée par de multiples
inondations zend air et maradi sont les
deux régions les plus touchées du pays à
travers cette saison des pluies de
régions qui sont frontalière du nigeria
des pluies torrentielles se sont
abattues à la mi juillet principalement
à travers tout le pays la population de
niamey la capitale mais aussi de sa
périphérie a été un peu plus ou moins
épargné jusqu'à présent mais la plus
grosse crainte à niamey aujourd'hui
c'est la montée du niveau du fleuve
niger
les ondes qui a été auparavant inondées
on a déjà prôné à déloger les
populations pour les relocaliser
ailleurs mais ils ont trouvé que à
chaque fois il y a une opportunité dans
cette relocalisation le titre revienne
après la saison des pluies vous serez
installé dans les mêmes zones inondables
et donc à ce problème doit être résolu
de façon claire mais pourquoi les
autorités nigériennes elles ont donné
depuis plusieurs mois des directives aux
riverains pour qu'ils quittent les
alentours du fleuve ainsi que les zones
les plus inondées à bhl de la capitale
depuis le début des sinistres c'est plus
de 12 mille maisons qui se sont
effondrées à travers le pays la saison
des pluies elles qui court jusqu'à
mi-septembre en principe devrait
continuer jusque là de menacer les
habitations les plus fragiles ici au
niger
allez on passe à la culture et ce soir
on reçoit les patrons le mythique groupe
ivoirien de zouglou qui fête ses 20 ans
de carrière et ils ont un concert samedi
prochain au zénith de paris merci à vous
alors éric patron et kembs aux patrons
merci et bienvenue dans le jt à france
24 vingt ans de carrière mais j'ai envie
qu'on revienne au point de départ alors
au départ c'est eric qui était dans un
autre groupe et vous rencontrez
clemenceau et qui lui aussi souhaite se
lancer dans la musique dite nous
justement ce qui a fixé à fonctionner
entre vous tout d'abord je voudrais dire
bonsoir à toute l'afrique bonsoir merci
faty matin et ben ça se fasse
naturellement voilà c'est des ambiances
facile qu'on appelle voyant communément
avec des tambours dj mines chacun était
dans sa commune et tous et puis on se
rencontre dans des funérailles dans des
cérémonies en tout cas et on s'apprécie
c'est comme ça que déjà on fait chemin
ensemble et après on rejoint un groupe
qu'on appelle un pégase heures du nombre
de 15 personnes et de la lui le
fondateur du groupe i dit on va faire
comme les grands frères salopards magic
system et autres on dit pourquoi pas
donc
on le suit et puis aujourd'hui ça donne
ce que ça donne après cinq albums et
plusieurs singles je pense qu'on essaie
de faire plaisir à notre chère patrie la
côte d'ivoire et à l'afrique en
développant notre façon à la culture et
nos traditions et nos valeurs j'entends
bien et alors le zouglou c'est un style
musical donc ivoiriens vous avez parlé
de magic system il ya beaucoup
popularisée dans le monde 1 mais tout en
restant à chaque fois très ivoiriens
vous vous définissez comment clemson ou
zouglou que vous faites chez les patrons
[Musique]
le zouglou
c'est ce qu'on fait c'est un zoug le
soft voilà parce que le zouglou
est à l'état de la société
voilà ce que les autres n'ont pas les
yeux pouvoir nous on dit ça haut et fort
c'est ça les goûts et les lycées c'est
une philosophie c'est inouï c'est une
philosophie et vous raconter aussi les
maux de la société effectivement et
alors je propose pour que faire une idée
plus claire pour nos spectateurs oppose
qu'on écoute un extrait du clip piqué et
on en parle juste après
tu ne comprends pas pourquoi
[Musique]
oui
alors ce clip date de 2019 mais je les
fais écouter pour qu'on passe qu'on voit
une pointe d'afro ya pas qu du zouglou
justement dans votre style eric vous
justement qu'est ce qui est important
pour vous aujourd'hui à transmettre au
delà du zouglou mais même si le zouglou
est important dans votre stylet qui fait
la particularité des patrons ben c'est
ce message de paix c'est comme le disait
un clou et sortir les mots voilà et les
problèmes de la société et voilà un peu
tout ce que le peuple dise et sans les
oublis comme le disait c'est une
philosophie vous savez en tant
qu'ivoirien en tant qu'africain on
traverse des crises depuis pas mal
d'années et je pense que cette musique
identitaire la côte d'ivoire arrive
justement à bien définir ou à mieux
sensibiliser les populations à l'instar
de tout ce que nous remarquons nous
constatons dans le continent est chez
nous en côte d'ivoire qui depuis 2010
art et cherchons la paix véritable et je
pense que nous sommes sur ce plateau
justement pour en faire passer ce
message de paix et qu'on va vraiment
vraiment mettre en valeur ce jour là le
dise du côté du zénith pour dire à tous
les ivoiriens que nous pouvons être
ensemble nous devons être ensemble car
nous savons être ensemble et c'est aussi
une façon d dit à tout le monde que
c'est un concert d'intégration africaine
c'est pour appeler tous les fils et
filles pour dire qu' on ne pourra pas
développer notre continent une patrie
si ce n'est que nous même et si on
laisse les gens nous dire à chaque fois
que le bourreau de l'afrique celle
africain ça veut dire que nous devons
prendre conscience et nous c'est ce
message que nous mettons dans nos
chansons dans nos textes et avec un
style de musique qui peut passer partout
donc souffler que se disent à partir de
16 heures que les choses machin comme on
dit aux houblons soir en poney et ça va
cohabiter à crépiter
alors revenons rapidement sur le style
musical justement est-ce que vous avez
des envies particulières de
collaboration ce qu'on entend un peu
d'un peu de zouk un peu de voix lasse et
les balades afro est ce qu'il ya des
envies musicales qui n'ont pas encore
été testée et qui pourraient l'être
bientôt d'avis ici parce que le zouglou
ça voyage le zouglou on peut s'adapter à
n'importe quel style musical voilà tel
que
l'afo travail pop il m'a parlé des
hypoglycémies adidas travaux va passer
les préfets mais la balle a vraiment ils
sont à six mois elle est de 10 août lady
di bill
quel moment a fait passer le message
écoute des débits des buts j'ai couru
comment tu veux faire entrer les paroles
assez limitées il faut tournoi voilà la
farouche zouk rnb parce qu'on a déjà
fait ça et puis comme comme sur le dis
on va rattraper si possible tous contre
tous tout ce dont manque avec ses
featurings là on est sur le territoire
français en train de prévoir des
collaborations à bas on entend on entend
le rendez vous est pris merci au patron
d'eads venu dans ce journal sur ce
plateau du jt à de journal la crique le
10 septembre rendez vous au zénith le
risque est pris bien entendu c'est ainsi
que nous refermons ce journal l'afrique
merci à tous ceux qui l'ont suivi en
côte d'ivoire est bien ailleurs
d'abidjan à mai à guy en passant par
kouassi kouassikro n'est ce pas rester
avec nous car l'actualité continue sur
france 24
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ici big flo et oli vous
êtes bien sur france 24
big flo et oli sont de retour en 2020
les rappeurs alors au top de leur
carrière avait créé la surprise en
annonçant faire une pause en france
parce que tu me reconnais après deux ans
d'absence musicale et médiatique
les deux frères toulousains retrouvent
leur public avec un quatrième album les
eaux c'est une carence genre à flot j'ai
peur qu'on sépare comme les daft punk
mais ces départs frères l'état pour ce
quatrième album rendez vous dans deux
ans on voit tous les deux ans avec
france 24 donc rendez-vous et triomphera
[Musique]